Oh a little justice club Oh Spanish
there are label slip on ran a new arena
it was so painful what you did to me
there's nothing bothering Deena I have
no time to chat
because me let's just run away and we'll
be waiting for you why would you be
waiting for me what may be waiting for
me I'm looking for a bite Jax Tara
unexpected
Henry sold fiber Tabassum was for losers
Olympus
I'm currently one of the three so not
alone a good cabinet member for Pirate
Captain Jack Sparrow
today's your lucky day as I just
happened to be Captain Jack no it can't
be
I've spent years searching for this the
great Jack Sparrow is not some
drunkenness sell-through even of a ship
a crew pants a great pirate does not
require such intricacy do you know how
long I've been waiting for this moment
the risks I've taken to be here you sure
you're Dean Jack stone how would you
like the guy pirate hang your inventor a
guillotine guillotine and Prince I love
the French did you know that they
invented mayonnaise how bad could it be
it's French
Hey
oh ah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's an idea for one with her good
old-fashioned spelling I I killed mr.
not now get the crowd involved doesn't
it
I should like to speak the vicar
municipality to me Carly I'm not one
complain normally this baskets for a
head
you